great so to move one step closer to
building awesome apps like the ones you
submitted to the discussion forum we're
going to learn about how to build up the
sunshine you I will do a quick recap
first to help remind you of the concepts
that you learned in Lesson one in order
to build a UI in Android we use views
views are rectangles on the screen and
we may or may not see the borders of
that rectangle essentially a view
handles drawing and event handling and
all the basic widgets in Android extend
from the space class the Android design
guide has visual examples of these basic
building blocks of apps for example we
have the basic text fields as well as
editable text fields you can do auto
complete on them and it comes with text
selection as well where pops up a
contextual action bar for you to copy
and paste
there's also buttons and also a
suggestion to use borderless buttons we
also have spinners where you can select
from a drop-down menu there's also
checkboxes radio buttons on/off switches
and we also have some progress bars
there's a ton more basic widgets here
and also in the Java Docs so check those
out and even ones that aren't listed
here so you'll come across them as you
need them now if you want to display
multiple views together you'll need a
view group a view group is a container
for children views here are a couple of
common view groups which Dan introduced
earlier first we have a frame layout a
child that gets added will be default
positioned in the top-left corner of the
view group if you add a second view here
it will overlap the first one so
typically we only have one child per
frame layout next we have a linear
layout it's composed of children either
in a horizontal row or in a vertical
column we can also specify layout weight
layout weight allows us to distribute
the width or height of a parent across
these children for example if this has
weight one and this has weight one then
the width of the parent can be split
across both of them evenly then we have
a relative layout where we can specify
that a view should be aligned to the
parents left top right or bottom edge we
can also specify that one view should be
relative to another view it doesn't fill
up the spaces nicely compared to a
linear layout but there are pros and
cons to each there's also a grid layout
where the views fill up cells in a grid
you can also have views that span
multiple cells I also want to point out
that a view group is a view so in our
code when we refer to a list item there
as being a single view that just means
the root view of the whole view
hierarchy for that layout chances are
that root view is a view group so it
contains children views as well as view
groups so basically you can nest view
groups within view groups the reason why
we care so much about parent-child view
relationships is because the way a child
view gets laid out depends on its parent
the simplest example of this is
specifying a views width and height but
now you've seen that every view requires
a height and width the two possible
values are either wrap content or match
parent this diagram shows all the
possible combinations for width and
height for this text view this is the
bounds of the view when we set wrap
content for height and width this is
what happens when we do match parent for
the width and match parent for the
height and this is what happens when
both are set as match parent if those of
the full dimensions of the parent if you
ran this on a device all of these would
visually look the same because you
wouldn't see these boundaries so why
does it matter which one we pick well it
matters as soon as you have other
children that need to be beside this
view and another reason is if you want
to specify gravity let me spend a quick
moment explaining gravity say for
example you have this textview within a
frame layout by default the text is
left-aligned and in this case no gravity
is set if we specify gravity equals
Center then it will Center the content
within the textview vertically it can't
move because it's already centered but
horizontally it does shift over to be in
the middle instead of this if we specify
layout gravity equal center that means
to Center horizontally and vertically
within the parent so we grab the whole
child textview and we move it in to the
center now it can't be centered
horizontally because it already takes up
the max width of the parent if we really
want to move the content to the middle
then we should specify wrap content on
this textview
so that it can be moved to the center
with this attribute you can also specify
padding and margin on views for example
if you added padding on this textview
then it would shift the content inside
by x amount on all sides if you specify
layout margin to the X then remember
that the parent is the one who will be
interpreting this
lay out pram in this case it adds a
margin of X all around the textview and
sexy was only this size when you render
both of these they would visually look
the same here's one case where it could
matter if this was a button and you
pressed it there could be a gray
background here showing so in some cases
you might want padding or margin or both
all views have a visibility property for
this image view it could be visible
invisible or gone if it's invisible then
it's not shown but there's still a
placeholder for it we still have to go
and measure the size of it if it's gone
then it's not even in the layout it's as
if it didn't exist in the XML you can
also toggle the visibility of a view
dynamically during runtime in the
Javadoc you can find all the possible
XML attributes for that class it also
shows inherited XML attributes for
example from the view class for this
image view and then it shows the
corresponding Java methods for those
attributes there was a brief rundown on
some basics to help us get started
but definitely check out the developer
site for more details later much like
the real world if you were working with
a team to build an Android app you would
start by implementing the wireframes
first this has a correct flow for how
the user will interact with the app but
it doesn't have the final visual look
and feel yet we'll build this up step by
step starting with the main activity
then we'll move on to the detail
activity and then later build up the
tablet UI then we'll receive a set of
visual mocks
red lines and assets all of this will
help us build a pixel perfect layout